what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
thanks for stopping by the channel today
there is a lot happening in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe right now and it
looks like things are about to get even
bigger in the MCU as it's been stated
that Marvel Studios has a really huge
announcement prepared for us for San
Diego Comic-Con while as far as what
they are going to be announcing we
believe that they're going to announce
two major things one is the official
fantastic forecast at least for the main
four members of the Fantastic Four maybe
not the villains but the actors who are
going to be playing Marvel's first
family the Fantastic Four team we hope
we get that but we also know that we are
most likely going to get the full reveal
of phase six and possibly the
rearrangement of phase five now last
year at San Diego Comic-Con Marvel
Studios announced a lot in Phase 5 alone
there were 12 different projects that
they announced and this isn't including
any of the special presentations that we
know they have in store for us they're
going to do one on Halloween and
Christmas plus not to mention we have
rumored special presentations coming for
the Silver Surfer Nova Ghost Rider it's
pretty jam-packed at this point but
Marvel Studios came out and said hey
we're gonna focus on producing less
content but that content is going to be
much better quality so for that reason
right there we know that Marvel Studios
was already shuffling around the
schedule as it was pushing some projects
back but they might actually kind of cut
some projects or push them back to after
phase six after the Multiverse Saga and
even in Phase seven after Secret Wars
there is a ton that is already expected
and rumored and we're gonna go over
everything in this video phase five base
six and phase seven what we know and
what has been rumored we're mainly going
to focus on phase seven but we'll
briefly touch on Phase 5 and phase six
now phase five we pretty much know but
the only thing is we don't know the
timetable now a lot of these projects
have already been pushed back so we can
expect a few more delays but as far as
we know right now what phase 5 consists
of is Ant-Man and the WASP quantumania
obviously along with Guardians of the
Galaxy vol 3 but upcoming a secret
Invasion and we have Loki season 2 the
Marvel's Echo blade ironheart Agatha
coven of chaos Daredevil Born Again
Captain America New World Order and the
Thunderbolts now we haven't heard
anything about the cancellation of any
of these series but what we did hear
recently is that Echo is going to be
arriving on Disney plus November 29th of
this year however they are going to
release all episodes at once on the same
day in binge format so Marvel Studios is
switching up their style a little bit
here this is most likely done so they
don't have everything so crammed
together the series doesn't have to end
six weeks later or two months later
making it possibly overlap with a movie
or making it really close to another
series or movie so I do think that this
is a pretty decent strategy from Marvel
Studios especially since they are
trained to have not too many projects
get delayed here also I might add that
X-Men 97 the animated series and what if
season 2 and season 3 were also supposed
to be a part of phase five so that's
even more however we don't have any
official release date for them yet but
as far as Phase 6 is concerned we're
really only sure about four different
projects at this point because that is
all that has been officially announced
for the Slate however we do know that
there are certain movies coming that
Marvel Studios needs to get out either
before Kang Dynasty or before Secret
Wars like Shang Chi 2. so right now
here's every project that could be a
part of phase six in the possible order
that they could be coming out and this
is just our best guess based off of the
information that is out there but fall
of 2024 we could see the Wonder Man
series this series is confirmed the cast
is stacking up right now and it's about
to get under pre-production pretty soon
in October 2024 we could get these
zombies animated series which we know
Marvel Zombies is confirmed also in
October we could be getting a ghost
writer special presentation this could
be their Halloween special that they do
also in the same year we could get
Spider-Man freshman year the Animated
Series we know that is official as well
then of course in November of 2024 we
have Deadpool 3 which everybody is
really excited for then in Fall of 2024
we could get the Vision Quest series the
series is also confirmed in Winter of
2024 we could get the Midnight Angel
Series this will be about okoyi and the
other midnight angels that we saw in
Black Panther 2 and this is one of the
confirmed wakanda series that Ryan
coogler will direct then in December of
2024 we are hoping to get Spider-Man 4.
in January of 2025 we could be getting
the Nova special then in February of
2025 it's the big one the Fantastic Four
then in Spring of 2025 we're hoping we
could get a midnight Sun's series or
movie and hopefully Moon night season 2.
then in in May of 2025 we get Avengers
the Kang Dynasty which is just going to
be absolutely huge in summer of 2025 the
X-Men 97 season 2 of the Animated Series
which has already been confirmed and in
July of 2025 we could be getting Shang
Chi too now the movie is confirmed they
just haven't given us any timeline for
it this time slot of July 2025 seems to
work because it's right after the Kang
Dynasty in summer of 2025 we could be
getting a Young Avengers series we know
the Young Avengers are basically being
set up in the MCU right now let's hope
we get an actual series from it in Fall
2025 we could be getting Spider-Man's
sophomore year which is the animated
series and follow-up to freshman year
that is confirmed then in October of
2025 for the Halloween special a perfect
one would be Mephisto there have been a
lot of reports about Mephisto entering
the MCU pretty soon and October of 2025
is not that far away plus he could enter
the MCU before then then in November of
2025 we have armor Wars which is a movie
now in Winter of 2025 we could be
getting the Nomad series that's been
ruined for a long time December 2025
could be the Abomination special which
is another rumor going around and
there's also been another rumor and this
could come in January of 2026 that we're
going to get a Kang the Conqueror series
or a special called the Conqueror which
I definitely think that Marvel should do
and I think it would be a great
positioning for Marvel to put it after
the King Dynasty but before Secret Wars
then in summer of 2026 we could be
getting an Illuminati series perhaps our
universe will finally get an Illuminati
team or perhaps it's going to be a
multiversal illuminati team then in
February 2026 we could get the Eternal
sequel eternals 2 it makes sense that
they would have a part to play in secret
Wars then from here are some rumored
series as well Miss Marvel season 2 and
of course World War Hulk which could be
a movie or could be a series we're not
sure about that right now and then of
course in May of 2026 the in end of
phase six in the entire Multiverse Saga
Avengers Secret Wars now out of all of
those projects that are confirmed and
rumored to be coming in phase six please
let us know what you are most excited
about in the comments down below and
let's dive into phase seven now now in
Phase seven we have no idea what the
timeline could be however we seemingly
do know some movies and Possible shows
that are confirmed and one could go in
Phase 7 but also could go in phase six
Doctor Strange three we know this has
confirmed the post-credit scene showed
us that Cleo arrived and clearly Doctor
Strange has messed up this is why it is
probably going in phase six somewhere
probably before the King Dynasty and
Secret Wars but it could also appear in
Phase seven now two rumored series are a
power packed series and secret Warriors
these two series have been rumored for
quite some time then Namor Namor is most
likely going to be getting a solo
project and this seems like it is pretty
much confirmed based off of the events
that happened in black panther 2 and no
more was phenomenal he was the best part
of black panther 2 and he was vicious he
killed he killed Queen raimonda that's a
pretty big death so I'm definitely
excited for a nemour solo project then
we have She-Hulk season two this has
been rumored to have been talked about
in Marvel Studios and will probably
happen and then one that is confirmed
that we recently did a video on of
course is the X-Men there is an X-Men
project plan from what we know the first
one is going to be titled the mutants
then there are two other series that
have been rumored which are agents of
Atlas this has been reported on by
insiders and a photon series that one's
just a rumor for now but if the Marvels
does really well and photon is received
very well they will most likely give her
a series then speaking of nemour we'll
have a black panther three now this will
most likely be about t'challa's son
although there will have to be a pretty
decent time jump in the MCU if t'challa
t'challa the second that is is going to
be all grown up or perhaps it could be
about him in his teen years and perhaps
we could finally get t'challa meeting
storm that's at least what I'm hoping
for but let us know your thoughts about
Black Panther 3 down below then we have
Kit harington's Black Knight this is
seemingly confirmed although we haven't
heard anything about a movie or a
project about it he's already debuted in
the MCU but the post-credit scene for
the eternals set him up to have his own
project or at least appear in another
project then there's a rumored Squadron
Supreme project which I think fans will
really enjoy I don't think a lot of
people know about the Squadron supreme
or the Squadron Sinister but if you are
curious look both of those groups up
because this could make for a very
excellent series then we have the 10
Rings project this was set up at the end
of Shang chi in the post-credits with
his sister xyling being the head of the
10 Rings now not dismantling them like
she was supposed to but becoming the
head of them then there's a rumored
Doctor Doom special now I would love
this but I would also love an entire
entire movie about Victor Von do there
is so much to his character that people
have not seen on screen I would be okay
with the series but I think a character
of his caliber deserves an entire movie
devoted to him and then of course we
have an X-Men 2 or a second mutant slash
X-Men movie and a fantastic four two
project and these are all the rumored
projects that we've heard for phase 7
the beginning of what I believe will be
called the mutant Saga but we'll have to
wait and see on that so there you have
it a ton of Marvel projects coming to
the MCU a lot of people have asked hey
do you think Marvel will slow down or
stop the MCU sometime well not anytime
soon as you can see between new projects
and sequels there are just a ton of
ideas a ton of projects that they could
possibly do and a ton of characters they
could give a lot of time to but hey go
ahead and let us know your thoughts
about this in the comments down below
did any project super stand out to you
that makes you super excited let us know
also don't forget to like the video
subscribe and leave a comment so you can
enter our giveaway for a chance to win
Xbox series X a PS5 some Marvel Legends
items or some DC items the winner gets
to pick one item and we pick a winner at
the end of each month also we now have a
full website that we post to every day
thecosmiconder.com a patreon and a
Discord server so I'll link those in the
description and then the pin comment
down below and don't forget to follow us
on Instagram and Twitter as well as
always thank you all so much for
watching woof woof
foreign